une dernière question pour notre médecin
on a appris récemment de mauvaises
nouvelles avec l'apparition pour
l'instant minoritaire c'est le cas de le
dire d'un nouveau variant est ce qu'on
peut craindre à l'apparition de nouveaux
variants qui résisterait aux vaccins
actuels pour le moment bien des nouveaux
variants en afrique du sud et au ces en
colombie mais pour le moment ils sont
sous surveillance strict ce qu'on
appelle des variants qui peuvent être la
seule chose qu'on sait ils sont
apparemment plus contaminant par rapport
à celui là mais pour le moment il semble
qu'ils ont pas pris la place du magasin
nike ce ne sont pas les bonnes nouvelles
comme si ces bonnes nouvelles je les
répare
on n'a pas la même définition une bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'il reste ils sont pas
elles ne prennent pas la place d'un
doublement il reste quand même voilà
donc qui sont sous surveillance il sent
pas non mais admettons qu'ils échappent
à la surveillance va pas on va pas
encore admettant mais je donne des
bonnes nouvelles et répondent par
rapport à au danemark parce qu'on dit
qu'il ya une dictature sanitaire en
france on parle pas du danemark parce
qu'on pour le prendre toujours comme
exemple le pass sanitaire au danemark
s'était depuis le mois d'avril là on est
au mois de septembre
ils ouvrent tout donc je pense que nous
on a commencé au mois de juillet
peut-être qu'au mois de novembre on va
ouvrir pour tout le monde c'est la bonne
année avec deux studios séparés pendant
toute la saison parce que là
effectivement ça confine à l'absurde